boys
thanks martin um so
welcome everyone to the northeast
devastation
[Music]
but would it be possible to do a roll
call of the members in the room just for
the record
um so in the room with me is uh
uh item one is apologies for absence so
we've got apologies from council dale
rennie and then council parking sending
may try and do a third
um
and then
[Music]
um
in terms of the is there's very little
to note until the base on their sponsors
position
and in terms of the capital
program can be exported obviously
lasting basis the general point is
pretty much on track we do have some
delays that have been made basis
excuse me chair um can i ask um
participants in the chamber to speak
closer to the microphones we're having
some difficulties uh picking up here
thank you
thank you
all again do you
absolutely not
happy to take any questions
um
has anybody else got any questions
and so i'm happy to meet
the recommendation just recommendation
one if you know that
um
excuse me chair
carl apps is joining the meeting surely
so um just bear with us oh yeah
thank you
uh
yeah
so paige
right um
the dungeon county council in their
wisdom have granted the council hundred
thousand pounds
uh for a project for the emotional
health and well-being of children and
young people
they have
uh the same amounts for bolster
and they have fairly narrowly defined
the parameters of
what needs to be done
and the purpose of this report is to
[Music]
look at um a collaboration with bolsa in
commissioning
um an organization to
do the work for us
and it's
it's hoped that the um
funding over beyond a year because it is
women's priorities of teaching public
health
um so um
that that really is it's a chair that um
that we
follow the recommendations to um agree
um the use of the investment money that
we've got from pcc
um
to deliver against the predefined
objectives
uh to agree a collaborative approach
pulls over
and also flexibility to extend beyond
the
initial annual funding
package
thanks
um
so then item
six is the pest control fees and charges
which is
um
so this is um
to make some amendments for pest control
fees and she will
um at the moment we sort of subsidize or
cross the council
that says two thousand pounds a year
it's one of our best control centers i
think it's really important that we want
to continue to run um but we do have a
lot
missed call-outs
that's the reason to introduce the
25-pound fallout charge and then we've
decided as a cabinet or a recommendat
[Music]
questions
[Music]
and so this is the review of flight of
the enforcement and
environmental expenditure notices
um so in environment we carried out um a
bit of a review into scientific
and i think
we've done a bit of a report throughout
this with some quite positive news of
what we've
managed
increase
i think from my perspective that's to
set quite a strong enforcement and
entertainment and obviously
using
some of that valuables
to invest in further determining
measures such as cctv cameras
um and then the third recommendation is
to review those obviously because it is
quite a sizeable increase in the 50
times just review that after 12 months
it's really nice to see the increased
enforcement and another car which
vehicle was seized just this week
and
the pandemics saw an increase in mighty
thing and
this is a good response to help the
enforcement team to
reduce the scale of the problem in
the district
very gratefully
yeah i think it's a really strong
[Music]
um
urgent business and then exclusion
republican press
so i'd
say
items there are none and so then item
nine is the exclusion of the public and
so i'm happy to move that the public
being sued from the meeting during the
discussion for
as if foreign involved with 12 aids
globally acts 1972 was named by local
women access to information variation
order 2006.
i'm happy to leave that
council
so that's carried so you're okay to stop
the live theme
you